[Music]
in 1978 Louise Brown became the world's
first baby to be born by in-vitro
fertilization or IVF her birth
revolutionized the field of reproductive
medicine given that approximately one in
eight heterosexual couples has
difficulty conceiving and that
homosexual couples and single parents
often need clinical help to make a baby
the demand for IVF has been growing IVF
is so common that more than five million
babies have been born through this
technology IVF works by mimicking the
brilliant design of sexual reproduction
in order to understand IVF we first need
to take a look at the natural process of
baby making believe it or not it all
starts in the brain roughly 15 days
before fertilization can happen the
anterior pituitary gland secretes
follicle stimulating hormone FSH which
ripens a handful of follicles of the
ovary that then release estrogen each
follicle contains one egg and on average
only one follicle becomes fully mature
as it grows and continues to release
estrogen this hormone not only helps
coordinate growth and preparation of the
uterus it also communicates to the brain
how well the follicle is developing when
the estrogen level is high enough the
anterior pituitary releases a surge of
luteinizing hormone LH which triggers
ovulation and causes the follicle to
rupture and release the egg once the egg
leaves the ovary it is directed into the
fallopian tube by the finger-like
fimbriae if the egg is not fertilized by
sperm within 24 hours the unfertilized
egg will die and the entire system will
reset itself preparing to create a new
egg and uterine lining the following
month
the egg is the largest cell in the body
and is protected by a thick
extracellular shell of sugar and protein
called the zona pellucida the zona
thwarts the entry and fusion of more
than one sperm the smallest cell in the
body it takes a man 2 to 3 months to
make sperm and the process constantly
renews each ejaculation during sexual
intercourse releases more than a hundred
million sperm but only a hundred or so
will ultimately make it to the proximity
of the egg and only one will
successfully penetrate through the armor
of the zona pellucida upon successful
fertilization the zygote immediately
begins developing into an embryo and
takes about three days to reach the
uterus there it requires another three
or so days to implant firmly into the
endometrium the inner lining of the
uterus once implanted the cells that are
to become the placenta secrete a hormone
that signals to the ovulated follicle
that there is a pregnancy in the uterus
this helps rescue that follicle now
called the corpus luteum from
degenerating as it normally would do in
that stage of the menstrual cycle the
corpus luteum is responsible for
producing the progesterone required to
maintain the pregnancy until six to
seven weeks of gestation when the
placenta develops and takes over until
the baby is born approximately 40 weeks
later now how do you make a baby in a
lab in patients undergoing IVF FSH is
administered at levels that are higher
than naturally occurring to cause a
controlled over stimulation of the
ovaries so that they ultimately produce
multiple eggs the eggs are then
retrieved just before ovulation would
occur while the woman is under
anesthesia through an aspirating needle
that is guided by ultrasound
most sperm samples are produced by
masturbation in the laboratory the
identified eggs are stripped of
surrounding cells and prepared for
fertilization in a petri dish
fertilization can occur by one of two
techniques in the first the eggs are
incubated with thousands of sperm and
fertilization occurs naturally over a
few hours the second technique maximizes
certainty of fertilization by using a
needle to place a single sperm inside
the egg this is particularly useful when
there is a problem with the quality of
the sperm after fertilization embryos
can be further screened for genetic
suitability frozen for later attempted
pregnancies or delivered into the
woman's uterus via catheter common
convention is to transfer the embryo
three days after fertilization when the
embryo has eight cells or on day five
when the embryo is called a blastocyst
and has hundreds of cells if the woman's
eggs are of poor quality due to age or
toxic exposures or have been removed due
to cancer donor eggs may be used in the
case that the intended mother has a
problematic uterus or lacks one another
woman called the gestational carrier or
surrogate can use her uterus to carry
the pregnancy to increase the odds of
success which are as high as 40% for a
woman younger than 35 doctors sometimes
transfer multiple embryos at once which
is why IVF results in twins and triplets
more often than natural pregnancies
however most clinics seek to minimize
the chances of multiple pregnancies as
they are riskier for mothers and babies
millions of babies like Louise Brown
have been born from IVF and have had
normal healthy lives the long-term
health consequences of ovarian
stimulation with ivf medicine
are less clear though so far IVF seems
safe for women because of better genetic
testing delayed childbearing increased
accessibility and diminishing costs it's
not inconceivable that artificial
baby-making via IVF and related
techniques could outpace natural
reproduction in years to come
[Music]